[inaudible].
Hey, what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and It's time for another tour of cities that I haven't done in
fucking years. Um, I don't even know what I'm driving right now.
This is one of the worst fucking cuts. Look into the back of this car. This,
there's no backup camera. I can't see shit, but a little side window there.
I'm almost almost took out this guy on a bike and he fucking freaked out on me
because what the fuck are you doing? I want to be like, well,
I'm doing what you would be doing if you're in the car. You know,
I'm not paying attention. I'm in a fucking car. So anyways, I'm in Phoenix,
Arizona. Uh, we're gonna slip this scared sports town here. All right.
I was screaming like, sorry, you gotta if you got a sports town here,
this is one of the worst names for an arena I've seen in awhile.
Talking stick resort arena.
We'll go down to the talking sticks. Fucking resort arena. Nothing.
I was like, you're going to get like a massage or something.
Get a parking garage. They are up here. You got your chase field.
It's where the, uh, I want to say devil rays, but it's the diamond backs.
This is, you know what I like about that place? Whenever I drive by them,
that's where they beat the Yankees. And now 2001 when even I as a red sox fan,
cause it was right after nine 11, I was like, alright, fuck it.
I'll root for this. I'll root for them. You know, it's good for the city.
And uh, then they lost.
So first good feeling I had that post nine 11, watching them loose.
This is this weird thing about this city of yours. What's the second one?
Like you leave the downtown area.
It just immediately becomes like road runner [inaudible] Shit.
Should I head back towards the downtown area? Well,
you don't have to pick out here. Dog's getting out. Jesus Christ.
That guy's base is so fucking,
it's big out here is other than really loud bass in the truck behind says
literally making my ears itch. Um,
I don't even, I can't even do this part of the video.
It was funny about that is it's shaken his whole car and he's just like,
just fucking up his suspension. All of it is just, just gradually coming loose.
It's like he's driving over a pothole when he's sitting still.
Why would you have it that loud dude?
I gotta fucking six sound system.
Not even a bass player would have the bass that louder. You know,
here the other instruments, is there anything worse than a Bass Solo
did? You can't fucking hear it.
I remember Billy Sheehan would always fucking have to Steve Vine and David Lee
rock. Steve Vine would be, Whoa, dude, all this fucking shit.
And then he come up and basically do the same thing. It was just like,
what do you like? What the fuck? Anyway,
she wants a big thing out here is a little dogs going missing.
Can't leave the gate open out here. It's just too many. You know,
it's too many coyotes, snakes. I don't know what the fuck gets him out here.
Pedophiles to do. There's always a sexual Predator on the desert. Right.
I think this is the number one place that sexual Predator is after they get out
of jail. You know, this is where they,
they usually settle down in the downtown Phoenix area. You know,
just like looking at all the sweaty kids. I don't know why I'm saying that.
I'm sorry.
Um,
[inaudible] Haley, a country song about a guy he was, Steve was take,
we sing on him and his dad flying at 15th and
[inaudible] pains. It's like, no you didn't. No you didn't.
They would never let that accent into, that's fucking billion dollar aircraft.
Whatever it costs. You know? Remember top gun.
Nobody had a southern accent and that did that.
What was chipping Dale's looking guys,
they all had like the Midwest accent in there.
Know what's funny is I actually liked this place with this. Just nothing. Like,
Oh my God, Jesus Christ.
Okay.
That's just a whole other level. All right. Don't, don't, don't,
don't show his head. My gun dude, he was dressed like a toddler.
He basically had on a onesy.
All right, now we're getting no real Phoenix. I showed you the nice area.
Here we go. I think I saw that. No country for old men that's been dumped.
McDonald's, they don't even have a playground. I had this here.
This is the [inaudible] America that Trump connected with, right?
[inaudible]
Jesus Christ.
Literally a hormone.
Alright, there's a guy sitting in the back of the pickup truck.
I mean this is like this guy's lit up with Chit and Hobo
back in the days you ride in box cars, but I guess trains don't exist anymore.
I love what you're afraid of. You won't even, it keeps catching us.
You got to know if you're sitting in the back of that ladies drinking out of his
jug, you looking at a guy, that guy has no social security number.
See that everybody perfectly good white guy. Look what happened.
You make the wrong decisions in life.
You know you end up in the back of a pickup truck and Phoenix, Arizona,
just hanging on for dear life fucking guy with a metal detector.
It was a weed whacker. Oh, I thought was a metal detector.
Lone Max cash loans on car titles. Jesus Christ.
How does that even work to come down? You can have your title in your car.
I'm going to take my title in there in exchange for cash and then I'm going to
go to the track. That's what I'm going to do. There you go. Horizontal strikes,
horizontal stripes. He likened his body something about being broken. This,
this type of heat. It just fucking beats the shit out of here.
There is a one call in this area that does not look to stolen.
Oh here we go. We're breaking out of urban sprawl.
Here's the landfill. This is the end of, this is the end of this shit.
All right, here we go. Uplifting.
Look at this poor bastard walking to work cause he brought his title down cause
you went to the track. Little river bed here. Some plenty's too and shit.
Right? Pale rider. Why would you advertise Brooklyn bedding here?
People are fucking sleeping on the ground.
Maybe it's for the all the people like me driving through it, right?
All of us privilege people. You guys like that? I wore a sweater.
This is my new thing to keep myself calm at. Wear sweaters were dead jeans,
you know, pair of Shell toes for a little flair.
And this is a Duke blue devil hat. You know, I know some of you are to be like,
when the fuck did you become a Finn?
Yeah know about three weeks ago when I went to a game, it was phenomenal.
Look at that right there.
That's something Richard wrongs would buy on gas monkey garage.
Like he walked up to that and he always has the other guy talk first and you
know, just to be like, so what do you thinking? I got mad.
I don't know why. I was thinking like tech grant, which Ah,
I can't, I, I can't do 10 grantees. And the guy's like, well what do you,
what are you thinking? I mean, I was thinking like four,
it's where they grow other weed. Is Weed legal in Arizona?
There's no way it's legal. There's no, they don't even celebrate.
They don't even celebrate Martin Luther King Gay.
There's no way they let you smoke a joint. Pawn shops are so fucking overrated.
Punk shops are so overrated. When you watch, what's that? What's it at?
Poncho pawn stars. Onstar? Yeah. When you watch pawn star,
you think you're going to go in there and there's going to be like a Superbowl
ring, like a Indian motorcycle and you get in there. It's just,
it's like a Casio keyboard. Somebody old apron.
It's like were resolved the good shit.
Cars. Twos, silver. What does it say? Cold guns.
Why gold guns? Gold. Gold guns.
Gold space guns. Oh, okay. Okay. Roger Martin was,
they had a rough weekend. Like, I believe that's a hospital.
If you get sick, I guess you go over there, you know as you do,
it's the fucking worst. There's no way.
When I get older there's no way I'm going. I'm not done.
I'm not dipping in the hospital. I'm like fuck it. Dying in there.
Listen to the respirator. The person next to me with that smell.
I hate hospitals. You know, I got,
and you know I got my affairs in order and one of them is just like,
you know when I'm in a bad way, pull the fucking plug.
I'm not going to be laying there like in that Metallica video cause everybody's
fucking talking around me. I didn't, I think I saw him move his toe.
Can you hear my voice in there and I'm just thinking on a loop.
All they'd kill me. Kill me. Kill me. I don't care if I'm going to help.
Let's just get it. Let's just get on, but then I'm ready to meet the devil.
Yeah.
Well it could be worse than just laying there in your fucking head.
You know? Right as you feel yourself dying. Oh good. I feel myself.
I'm starting to die and that you just feel it.
Injecting nutrition into your arm.
Can you cry when you were in a coma?
Good. That happened. I don't know.
I wonder if that's a good taco. Hey,
let's find a good place to get something to eat this best.
You want to get a Taco? I don't know about this place. Inventive burritos.
Inventive burrito means a white guy's making
Mexican infused.
What do they have against cutting the grass out in these fucking desert places?
Church's chicken, KFC, auto zone. Big Gun parliament.
It's the same fucking 12 stores. Do you know what he does about broke areas
in the south west versus the east coast is at least like the land is lush back
on the east coast. Like this shit just looks so fucking dead.
It's like tumbleweeds and stuff. It just looks extra broken.
My Dad's still fucking half 15 so yet you still have your cowboy hat on.
[inaudible]
this is like a thing. If you fly like at 50 Joseph, they'd be like good looking.
You know what I mean?
You can't come in there with that fucking country bumpkin bullshit.
You got to lose that accent. Get yourself a little high and tight haircut.
Go in there with your fucking cowboy boots. You don't have to do this.
Those fucking loaded ticks after all those years are riding bulls and shooting
wild boar or they put them on that little fucking was that ride the centrifuge,
Turkish twist, whatever they put them at, will you face starts doing this shit?
You know, they just said they gone, whew.
It's gonna take a lot more, a lot more than that. You know,
going around in a circle of scare redneck. You know what I mean?
They put dynamite and old lawnmowers blowing their legs off.
You seen that video? Blew my leg off.
This guy blows his leg off and that's what he says. I blew my leg off.
That's it. Where's the screaming? Oh Yeah, God, I lights.
I'm going to get your belt and you just blew my leg off.
Probably called his mom. Mom,
mom's me. I blew my leg off.
Nah, I'm not going to be home.
Let's try to think of a good cowboy. Name's Jesse. I blew my leg off.
[inaudible]
Jesse won't be here today. He blew his leg off shooting in an old tractor.
That's what this guy did. He had an old fucking tractor.
He filled it up with this explosive and there's some sort of like, you know,
ratio for whatever pounds of explosives,
the amount of feet you have to be away from it. And he didn't do that. You know,
like when you put together something, you just throw the directions out.
He did that with like fucking dynamite and he stuck in an old mom.
No riding mower, just that blade alone, if that came flying out,
you would take your fucking head off and he stand it. You know,
like he already shot something and now he's just going for the kill shot.
Just walked right up to it, shoots the thing.
Your camera goes like that and he falls down. He just goes, I blew my leg off.
[inaudible]
you got to tell that story for the rest of your fucking life.
How'd you lose your leg? We in Fallujah. Nah,
I put a bunch of dynamite, an old tractor and I uh, was Bob
Seven, eight feet away from it and I started shooting at it
and you know, it blew up and it did, took my leg with it.
Was it painful? Oh yeah. Oh yeah. Who you screaming now?
What'd you do? I just stated the obvious gloom leg.
It's like an endless character. You want to come in your mouth? No,
he'd say it after Kevin. Your mouth. Oh,
there's a fucking hotel. We did it. It was perfect.
This really isn't a tour as much as I'm telling stories cause there's nothing to
see here.
This is one of these areas where they just put a bunch of shops and they try to
get human beings to sort of gather.
We'll put an urban outfitter as an anchor store. Then we'll have a chipotle.
What else do people like to do? I Dunno, man.
I've just always been a truth teller. If there's just truth laying on the table,
I just gotta say it. The balls stuck to my leg.
Can I start with the salad? The overshare guy.
[inaudible] I don't even know what it is. Chipotle lay. There you go.
[inaudible]
that's all good jogging that fat people do. They run.
They try to make a light to go into chipotle and I'm kidding.
They would go to cvs.
Oh, Bill with the low house. Stand up. Look at stand up live comedy theater.
From what I heard, it's one of the biggest comedy clubs,
one of the biggest comedy clubs in North America.
[inaudible]
as far as, he's fucking hilarious.
This shit he gets amped up about, dude. You know what I like?
Do you want to like, I like mustard.
Is there anything better than mustard on a sandwich? May. It just, it's crazy.
It's great. Who did really like is the listener. It's like,
where do I take that conversation? What'd she, Paul,
what do you think about man, don't like it. Not a mayonnaise guy.
It's a sandwich.